I'm standing here by the Google
corkboard server rack this server rack
was built in nineteen ninety nine by
Google employees simply because you
could not buy the computers required to
achieve the scale reliability and
performance that Google required each
row here has eight hard drives on it and
for complete pcs and there is a cork mat
to shield the electronics from the metal
frame that carries the row up that's why
it was called the Google cork board
server rack when your application runs
on the Google cloud platform you can be
sure it runs on the latest and best
hardware well perhaps not this version
from 1999 but the latest version that we
built so in this lesson we're going to
cover the heavy duty stuff we'll start
it off by looking at memcache a great
way to optimize the performance of your
application then we look at background
jobs in the form of push queues pull
queues and cron jobs and we'll wrap it
up by looking at some of the scaling and
tuning parameters for App Engine let's
get started shall we